[Musique]
bienvenue dans auditions publiques
l'émission politique commune à LCP et
publique Senna une heure un invité et on
a plaisir ce soir de recevoir Olivier
marlex bonsoir vous êtes président du
groupe LR à l'Assemblée nationale comme
chacun le sait ici au programme de cette
émission le coup de théâtre de la
surprise du chef Emmanuel Macron qui
décale d'un mois la présentation de la
réforme des retraites pour laisser
officiellement au nouveau chef de partie
le temps d'entrer dans la concertation
quelle est votre interprétation de ce
décalage est-il heureux qu'elles en sont
les conséquences
qu'est-ce que vous êtes prêt à voter
dans le fond 65 64 ans pour rage légal
Brigitte Boucher est intranet vous
poseront toutes ces questions l'avenir
de votre droite il en sera question avec
Yves Thréard Éric Ciotti désormais
président du parti c'est votre confrère
à l'Assemblée nationale fossoyeur ou
sauveur des LR il vous interroge poser
les questions d'actualité avec Vincent
on parlera entre autres de foot avec une
certaine demi-finale France Maroc
mercredi soir mais justement tiens à
propos de foot le lendemain matin il
devait y avoir la présentation de la
réforme des retraites par Elisabeth
borne et Emmanuel Macron à la surprise
générale quand même il a pris le cours
tout le monde un danser tout à l'heure
un décalage d'un mois est-ce qu'il a
raison je crois que le Président de la
République a fini par se faire peur tout
seul quoi c'est à dire que à force de
peut-être un peu par Brava de d'agiter
de chiffres de 65 ans pour le recul de
départ à la retraite
dans un pays qui a réussi exploit quand
même de se mettre à dos absolument tous
les syndicats y compris les plus modérés
ceux qui sont pas hostiles par principe
à une réforme des retraites et donc je
crois qu'il a vu le il a vu le le risque
et il a préféré essayer de laisser
passer les vacances de Noël des
françaises qui me paraît ce qui me
paraissent la réforme des retraites elle
est alors sur
font et c'est très important de
important de comprendre quel est votre
position les éléments lex parce qu'on
s'y perd un peu il y a différentes
lignes quand même dans votre famille on
verra mais encore une fois sur Emmanuel
Macron comment vous interprétez ce
décalage est-ce que c'est pour
éventuellement reculer un peu sur le
fond justement parce qu'il se fait peur
ou est-ce que après tout un peu plus de
temps 4 semaines laissez passer Noël
après tout s'est passé
je pense que s'il était sûr de lui et de
sa réforme il n'aurait pas reculé donc
c'est que c'est un sujet sur le fond ce
sujet sur le fond c'est que après
plusieurs hésitations on en a parlé de
64 ans puissant assemblée revenir à 65
ans qui était d'ailleurs une toute
première version je crois qu'il s'est
rendu compte que cette tâche 65 ans
était sans doute trop brutale donc à
votre avis c'est pour reculer sur le
fond du texte sur ces 65 ans qui devait
être présenté par Isabelle barent
des conflits dans le pays et que les
vacances de Noël des Français étaient
pas le meilleur moment et que l'hiver un
peu froid que nous risquons d'avoir
pas de capacité de puissance nucléaire
disponible pour nous chauffer risque de
faire un contexte un peu compliqué il
fallait laisser les Français tranquille
à Noël
pour pidolienne ne pas emmerder les
Français à Noël c'était ça
les abandonner moi je pense que il faut
faire une réforme de retraite
et on va voir comment elle est
importante et il faut le faire en ayant
le souci qu'elle soit acceptée par les
Français c'est une affaire pour les
Français qu'il faut faire et pas pour
les marchés financiers comment dans
quelques instants vous aviez rendez-vous
mercredi avec la première ministre sauf
erreur c'était à votre agenda
peut-être plus de temps pour son
rendez-vous d'accord je cite quand même
le communiqué de l'Elysée cela permettra
ce délai d'avoir quelques semaines de
plus pour que celles et ceux qui
viennent de prendre des responsabilités
puis sur quelques éléments clés de la
réforme échanger avec le gouvernement
c'est l'élection d'Erickson qui a joué
remercier Eric chioti d'avoir sauvé nos
vacances d'avoir évité une grève des
trains et voilà donc vous voyez que
l'élection président des républicains a
quelque chose déjà de très utile bon bah
écoutez on y reviendra là aussi sur le
fond avec Yves réa Brigitte boucher et
tam-traini bonsoir à toutes les deux et
cette réforme cette réforme cruciale
pour Emmanuel Macron comment vous
l'envisagez-vous c'est à VOUS Tam
d'abord et bien de l'âge légal de le
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 65 ans est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec un tel report
moi je suis d'accord sur l'idée que il
faut réformer notre système de retraite
pourquoi parce que dans notre pays
aujourd'hui on a trop de nos
compatriotes qui ont des petites
retraites des niveaux de retraite
totalement indignes d'un grand pays
comme comme le nôtre
fait le gouvernement aujourd'hui juste
un chiffre 30% des dis pas assez je suis
pas sûr que je trouve ça motivation la
motivation première du gouvernement
c'est envoyer un signal au marché
financier parce qu'ils ont des
inquiétudes sur leur sur la dette du
pays et qui n'en fait aucune réforme par
ailleurs notamment sur le budget de
l'État et donc pardon il y a 30% des
Français aujourd'hui qui sont ce qu'on
appelle au minimum contributif c'est à
dire qu'on une retraite alors qu'ils ont
travaillé toute leur vie toute leur vie
qu'ils ont tout leur trimestre de 741
euros plus éventuellement un petit bout
de complémentaires ces niveaux là sont
indignes sur votre capable d'augmenter
les retraites il y a pas de il y a pas
de secret il faut il faut être capable
faire entrer un peu plus d'argent dans
le système et donc ça veut dire
l'aéroport de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite aujourd'hui on est à 65 ans on
est à 62 ans avant d'aller il y a un âge
qui 63 ans avant d'aller à 64
gouvernement n'agit pas de chiffon rouge
inutile 65 ans 2031 j'ai l'occasion de
voir Olivier dupe en 2031 plus personne
sera là vous serez plus là peut-être non
plus donc c'est ridicule est-ce qu'un
gouvernement a fait un autre pourra le
faire donc pourquoi JT ce chiffon rouge
que de de de 65 ans
Valérie Pécresse ou François Fillon
2017-2022
et c'était surtout dans un projet de
redressement un peu global là les
Français ont bien compris que le
redressement il n'était pas global on
vient de voter un budget
158 milliards de déficits 0 effort sur
la dépense publique les seuls à qui on
demande un effort c'est aux Français qui
travaillent au dernier conseil qui vient
d'être élu président de la République
65 ans donc je sais pas pourquoi pas
Eric mais une fois encore tout est une
question de de démarche donc très
clairement ce que j'ai fait observer au
gouvernement c'est je pense que s'il
mettait comme objectif sur la table à 63
ans à la fin du quinquennat en 2027 je
pense que c'est une réforme lentement
avec vous vous dites absolument qu'il
faut faire des recettes supplémentaires
on a fait des réformes jusqu'à présent à
chaque fois qu'on a eu le courage on a
pas eu si souvent c'est la droite qu'il
a fait de reculer de l'âge de la
retraite on a fait d'un trimestre par an
donc je propose qu'on reprenne cette
cette méthode ce qui nous amènerait à 63
ans dans les quatre ans la fin du
quinquennat bonne nouvelle ou mauvaise
lettre ce n'est plus que dans quatre ans
Emmanuel Macron avec ses 65 ans il joue
à quoi alors
je pense qu'il s'amuse à jouer les une
espèce de redemontade c'est un peu
bravache
au point que d'ailleurs il commence à se
rendre compte que tout ça compliqué les
choses admettons que le gouvernement
reste 63 ans à la fin du quinquennat
peut-être une accélération du Touran si
vous faites les deux vous refaites
rentrer plus de 10 milliards dans le
dispositif et vous avez les moyens de de
d'augmenter les retraites nous notre
objectif c'est pas du tout la même voix
que celle des 1200 euros ça c'est un
vrai objectif que les Français peuvent
comprendre
de la position des des sénateurs LR qui
depuis des années
chaque année le Sénat vote 64 ans un
horizon qui est dans 10 ans et donc qui
propose 63 ans à la fin j'ai relu leur
amendement avant de venir il propose
aussi 63 ans en 2027 à la fin du
quinquennat du Sénat si il y a un accord
sur ce que propose le Sénat oui moi je
pense qui lui affiche 64 ans qui n'a pas
peur d'afficher 64 ans vous avez peur
même si c'est pas le fond vous lâchez
pas moi je me souviens j'étais
collaborateur de président Sarkozy quand
il a fait la seule réforme de retraite
un peu solide qu'on ait fait jusqu'à
présent
Nicolas Sarkis s'est posé la question de
savoir quel âge il fallait mettre en
perspective des français où était
l'acceptabilité de de la réforme et il
avait considéré qu'à l'époque fallait
faire l'arriver à 62 ans aujourd'hui je
crois que même le même à redit que avant
d'aller à 64 ans de toute façon il
fallait passer par 63 donc 63 ans dans 4
ans voilà voilà une réforme je pense que
ça m'est pas les Français dans la rue et
c'est une réforme ça le mérite d'en être
une admettons que le gouvernement reste
sur ses 65 ans est-ce que vous vous y
opposé à ce que vous déposez une motion
de censure
tout est question une fois encore de
calendrier mais je pense que agiter ce
chiffre de 65 ans aujourd'hui alors
qu'on ne fait que les gouvernements ne
fait aucun effort par ailleurs de
réduction de la dépense publique ce ne
serait pas compris par les Français ce
serait compris comme une provocation et
donc notre soutiendrait pas cette
réforme
on en est pas on en est pas là mais oui
c'était parti
des hypothèses sérieux
on ferait entendre notre désaccord avec
les moyens dont nous disposons vous
savez que ça pourrait emporter largement
l'hémicycle ça pourrait pour le coup
avant de grosses conséquences si on
considère que il faut on fait partie de
ceux c'est pas le cas de tout le monde à
l'Assemblée nationale considéré qui
considère que pour augmenter les
retraites il faut faire une réforme de
retraite si on veut arriver à ce 1200
euros minimum de retraite il faut faire
il faut faire une réforme bien
commençons rapidement
allons-y pas à pas 63 ans d'ici la fin
du quinquennat trimestre par an ce
serait déjà ce serait déjà pas mal en
tout cas je serais beaucoup mieux que ce
que Monsieur n'a pas fait de plus 5 ans
vous l'avez dit vous serez reçu par les
abeilles borne mercredi qu'est-ce que
vous allez lui demander
je vais je vais déjà écouter ce qu'elle
a ce qu'elle a à me dire c'était elle
qui c'est elle qui consulte je fais lui
demander ce qui est pas de provocation
c'est ce que je dis à du soft déjà c'est
à dire pas agité ce chiffre de 65 ans
qui est une perspective lointaine donc
c'est un peu ridicule de de
créer de l'anxiété quand vous lui avez
parlé dessus oui alors il m'a dit mais
c'était dans votre programme j'ai dit
oui mais enfin nous on avait un problème
de redressement du pays ce qui n'est pas
votre cas vous vous avez 158 milliards
de déficits on peut pas dire que vous
cherchez à faire des efforts sur la
dépense publique est-ce que ça veut dire
changer de véhicule législatif
aujourd'hui on devrait passer par un
projet loi de finance rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale a priori à passer en
force autant de fois qu'on le veut donc
c'est pas c'est sûr que c'est pas un bon
signal pour pour la concertation une
fois encore si le gouvernement était
capable de de faire un projet un petit
peu un peu sérieux dans lequel il faut
retrouver la question des la dernière
langue plus vous décalez les carrières
là je pardon plus évidemment faut du
proportion décaler l'âge de pour les
carrières prendre en compte les
carrières longues il y a la question des
fins de la pénibilité la question des
des fins de carrière avec notamment les
dispositifs de cumul emplois retraite
qui aujourd'hui sont ne fonctionne pas
bien si le gouvernement arrivé à faire
quelque chose de sérieux n'aurait pas
besoin de de cette menace j'ai 49-3 le
jeu n'est pas fait à dit Yaël brande
pivel la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale vous pensez que malgré la
réforme qui pourrait être proposée il y
aurait des marges de négociation encore
au Parlement
le Parlement il sort il sert à ça donc
c'est pour ça que une fois encore la
question de la méthode choisie par le
gouvernement et très et très important
et puis derrière c'est aussi le message
qu'on envoie aux Français c'est on a une
Assemblée nationale qui arrive malgré
tout à travailler je la loopy était
adoptée
de l'Assemblée nationale enfin ça veut
dire que là ils vont avoir besoin des
voix de la droite là ils ont décidé de
reporter au 10 janvier parce que
justement éric ciotier a été élu
président des républicains c'est une
main tendue quand même à la droite pour
pour voter ce texte non vouloir majorité
donc pas de majorité et donc moi je
préférais effectivement qu'ils essaient
de faire quelque chose
qui rejoignent ce que nous proposons qui
effectivement d'allonger un peu la durée
de cotisation donc vous irez sur le pour
pouvoir redistribuer un peu plus à nos
compatriotes on est tout à fait en ligne
avec avec ce que propose les sénateurs
au dîner à l'Elysée la semaine dernière
justement sur les retraites il a été
décidé de ne pas traiter directement
avec vous pour sur cette question des
retraites mais individuellement parce
que peut-être vous ne tiendriez pas
l'ensemble de vos collègues dans le
groupe
Parlement m'a dit que évidemment j'étais
pas vrai
s'il pense pendant la République veut
faire mon travail aller rencontrer les
62 députés individuellement voilà non tu
savais pas très n'est pas très sérieux
enfin notre groupe a réussi jusqu'à
présent à avancer de manière assez
collective ça nous plaît pas on le dit
très clairement on ne vote pas sur
l'immigration on a fait entendre
par exemple qui est contre le report de
Las Vegas de départ à la retraite
proposition s'il parle de de 45 ans
qui propose Aurélien Pradier vous dites
qu'il propose
c'est une façon de minimiser des lignes
qui soient différentes que chacun est
aboutit sa réflexion totalement sur le
sujet on la connaît
je l'ai convaincrai et viendront sur ma
ligne d'avoir une proposition totalement
ficelle alors qu'on ne connaît pas le
projet du gouvernement
de ce que j'ai compris la pollution de
de Aurélien pradieuste et qui voulait
qu'on compte plutôt en annuité parce que
je dis en année de cotisation et pas en
âge couperait la difficulté c'est qu'en
fait avec la réforme Touraine on va déjà
être à 43 années de cotisation donc pour
rajouter deux ans ça voudrait dire 45
ans
45 ans pour des gens qui rentrent sur
marché de travail vous savez qu'en
France on rentre sur ma cheville à 22
ans
ça fait une retraite à 67 ans donc je
suis pas sûr voilà que que chacun est en
tête exactement vous allez les prendre
les uns après les autres vous et leur
dire et vous leur expliquerez sur quoi
ils doivent pour l'instant c'est pas
toujours 49 3 on est dans une période
budgétaire où il y a des 49-30 cascade
ce weekend c'était le 9e recours au 49-3
avec Elisabeth borne encore dans
l'hémicycle et puis elle vous a fait un
reproche pas vous mais aux oppositions
on l'écoute
[Applaudissements]
c'est voilà les rires qui ont accueilli
les riches je crois que c'est ouvert les
rires qui ont accueilli reniquent les
rires les réactions dans l'hémicycle
qu'est-ce que vous vous avez pensé de
cette sortie de la première ministre
encore un peu sur le registre de la
provocation parce que je crois que le
débat dans l'émission a duré quelques
secondes 30 secondes donc c'est le le
débat sur une autre finance le plus bref
de la Cinquième République
je regrette que le gouvernement est
engagé sa responsabilité aussi vite
qu'il engage sa responsabilité
malheureusement le comprend il y a pas
de il y a pas de majorité donc il y a
pas d'autre choix
d'un texte donc pas de pas
d'incompréhension de la consommation
majeure il faut bien qu'un budget soit
adopté on est en désaccord avec ce
budget on ne peut pas envisager de le
voter donc voilà il y a pas d'autre
choix j'ai hâte qu'on arrive dans une
période où
l'usage du 49-3 sera plus compliqué et
vous sera possible pour un texte une
fois dans une dans la navette et donc au
Parlement retrouvera tous ses droits
de réunions du Conseil national de la
refondation Emmanuel Macron a une
critique vis-à-vis de ce qui n'y
participent pas il dit ceux qui sont mal
à l'aise avec le Conseil national de la
refondation ce sont les défenseurs du
corporatisme qui est une maladie
française est-ce que vous êtes
corporatif Olivier Marleix
du Parlement des institutions de la
République ce CNR c'est une espèce
d'objet non identifiée dont j'observe
sincèrement qui sort quand même pas
grand chose pour l'instant
au moins le report l'annonce du report
de gouvernement qui fut le débat à
l'Assemblée nationale
et qui qui crée le débat le sens de
discussion là où il le veut même la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale a
rappelé quand même que le l'enceinte
pour le débat démocratique dans notre
pays s'appelle le Parlement voilà rien
d'autre alors il y aura des débats
justement à l'Assemblée sur le projet de
loi énergie renouvelable ils vont se
poursuivre toute cette semaine avec un
vote probablement on y voit déjà un peu
plus clair sur ce texte est-ce que vous
allez comme les sénateurs les
républicains votez ce texte
ça commence ça commence à mal ces débats
enfin on a fait une semaine on a vu que
le gouvernement a tricoté
consciencieusement les quelques mesures
de protection que le Sénat avait à
l'introduit le grand défaut de ce texte
c'est un texte il fait essentiellement
pour dérouler de l'éolienne allemande et
du panneau photovoltaïque chinois
ça pourrait ne pas être que ça et le
gouvernement est resté sourd à toutes
les mesures de protection des paysages
que nous avons proposé des énergies
renouvelables c'est beaucoup d'autres
sujets finalement
il y avait quelques apports si tout ça a
disparu je pense qu'on va se poser
beaucoup moins de beaucoup moins de les
énergies renouvelables c'est beaucoup
d'autres sujets c'est c'est l'hydrogène
c'est la méthanisation
j'ai lu un rapport de la situation
France hydrogène qui est des acteurs de
la filière qui attendent que le
gouvernement prenne des décrets il
s'agit de simples décrets du
réglementaire pas besoin de tout ce
cinéma à l'Assemblée pour faciliter le
déploiement de des activités d'hydrogène
en France pour l'instant il se passe
rien sur la méthanisation on pourrait
imaginer là aussi que le gouvernement
prenne par arrêter des mesures pour
débrider la production de les capacités
de production de biogaz dans notre pays
il en fait rien donc on est un texte de
communications de l'industrie chinoise
moi ça m'enthousiasme pas j'aurais
préféré qu'on ait des filières
françaises et on a vraiment le sentiment
que des Allemands ayant couvert leur sol
d'éoliennes ont besoin de nouveaux
marchés qui sont venus taper à la à la
porte du ministère de l'Environnement on
leur a dit allez-y vous gênez pas vous
pourriez vous abstenir sur ce texte ou
ça mér dans votre contrat des mesures de
protection qu'on demande ce sera ce sera
compliqué de de voter
il y a aucune mesure de protection dans
les périmètres on a proposé des
périmètres élargi sur les monuments
historiques qui est absolument rien donc
pour l'instant le pour l'instant le
compte n'y est pas du tout il n'y a pas
vraiment de zone d'exclusion
donc non c'est intègre pour faciliter le
déploiement des des éoliennes est-ce
qu'on reproche surtout au gouvernement
c'est de faire les choses totalement à
l'envers c'est à dire que on commence ce
texte en sans avoir redéfini nos besoins
nos besoins d'énergie on dit que la
nouvelle programmation plus Granelle de
l'énergie on la fera après j'aurais
préféré qu'on la fasse avant pour savoir
de combien de parcs éolien en mer on a
réellement besoin donc tout ça il fait
un peu un peu à l'envers alors on sait
que l'énergie va peut-être manquer en
2023 Emmanuel Macron a dit
répondre
donc là
Emmanuel Macron dit pas de panique vous
faites confiance au gouvernement pour
qu'il y ait pas de coupure d'électricité
en 2023
qui n'aurait pas de coupure en octobre
finalement il y aura peut-être des
coupures après il dit pas de panique ce
qui est pas le mot qui est le plus
rassurant qui soit dans la bouche d'un
président de la République bon tout ça
et tout ça est absolument la réalité
c'est que oui il y a des risques de
coupure pourquoi des risques de coupure
parce que on sait qu'on a eu jusqu'à 31
réacteurs nucléaires à l'arrêt qui leur
reste près d'une d'une vingtaine on sait
ce qu'on a de retard d'ailleurs dans le
retour de ces réacteurs nucléaires
sur le sur en capacité de de production
là où on tablette sur 50 gigawatts de
puissance disponible pour la fin de
l'année on est en réalité qui a 40
gigawatt depuis quelques jours donc il
manque 10 gigawatts c'est c'est c'est
énorme c'est à peu près l'équivalent
enfin on peut on peut importer 12 13 14
gigawatts grand maximum et en
conséquence donc ça veut dire que en
janvier février c'est RTE qui le dit on
risque vraiment si il y a des épisodes
de froid on risque des coupures pour
l'instant on s'en sort ce qu'il faut
avoir en tête et ce qui est absolument
navrant concernant pour notre pays on ne
s'en sort que parce que notamment les
industries
ont baissé considérablement leur
activité j'entendais la ministre de
l'Énergie
les collectivités locales non le premier
contributeur malheureusement c'est le
secteur industriel avec avec un une
baisse de de de production qui est liée
une baisse d'activité liée à l'explosion
des coûts de l'électricité pour eux
les Britanniques par exemple n'ont pas
la possibilité de se chauffer il y a des
il y a plein de courants de chroniques
la situation on devrait pas
investir si on avait un tout petit peu
anticipé tout ça en se posant les
questions moi je serai curieux de savoir
combien Monsieur Lévy a fait de réunions
l'année dernière à l'Elysée pour
organiser les villes anciens présidents
on ne parle pas du tout dans notre pays
de la question de l'explosion des coûts
d'électricité c'est absolument pas comme
ça non malheureusement pas assez parce
que
européen de l'électricité j'interpelle
le gouvernement sur le fait qu'il faut
sortir de ce marché européen de
l'électricité on est alors à laquelle
nous parlons malgré toutes les aides on
va mettre l'État va mettre 45 milliards
d'euros de d'aide malgré tout la France
les entreprises françaises vont payer
leur électricité deux fois plus cher que
les Allemands c'est un comble si on
avait adopté la règle espagnole et
portugaise de sortie de ce de ce marché
européen on serait il aurait fallu
le prix du gaz
une fois qu'on aura mis ce 5 milliards
sur la table pour
l'essentiel de la production en France
on serait un prix moyen de 50 euros on
est à 500 euros
et les échanges d'électricité mais
simplement pourquoi imposer aux Français
un prix de marché et pourquoi elle est
subventionnée on va subventionner de
l'argent public qu'on emprunte un prix
de marché qui est un prix totalement
mensuel il faut qu'on avance encore une
question sur chaque carburant rapidement
est-ce que c'est un coup de pouce qui
vous semble bienvenue malheureusement
c'est beaucoup moins efficace que que ce
que nous avions obtenu cet été avec avec
une vraie remise à la pompe ce que
j'observe bien oui c'est de l'argent
public faut faire attention ça va coûter
j'essaie de faire
modestes
100 fois 10 millions donc c'est un
milliard
ce que j'aurais juste vous rappeler
c'est que l'État nous taxe taxe et
français auteur de 33 milliards par an
sur le carburant donc c'est à dire qu'on
le rend de la petite monnaie en réalité
voilà
taxe moi les français pour avoir pour
leur donner moins d'aide derrière ce
gouvernement adore donner les aides à
bord distribuer les chèques c'est devenu
c'est devenu une habitude c'est de le
mode de gouvernement du président de la
République c'est de faire des chèques
alors une question sur une annonce
d'Emmanuel Macron la semaine dernière
sans transition une annonce sur le
préservatif pourquoi est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec la gratuité des
préservatifs pour les moins de 25 ans
sur le sur le sur le fond sur le fond
pourquoi pas mais très sincèrement dans
la situation dans laquelle est notre
pays
3000 milliards de dettes 158 milliards
de déficit un commerce extérieur qui
s'effondre et qui pas d'aujourd'hui pas
à cause de la crise
évidemment
on était jusqu'à l'année dernière le
premier but la première premier pays
exportateur d'électricité on va manquer
de
service public
nos services publics s'écroule etc
l'hôpital s'écroule et plein de la
République n'a rien d'autre n'a rien
trouvé de mieux à dire aux Français que
de leur proposer le préserve gras City
le problème c'est qu'il le disent ou
qu'il ne fasse pas par ailleurs des
économies parce que c'est pas la
priorité c'est la santé des jeunes c'est
comme une priorité aujourd'hui
et ce besoin d'aller communiquer sur Tik
Tok pour annoncer je sais pas quoi
démagogique c'est ça
le président de la République a beaucoup
autre chose à faire pour essayer de
redresser beaucoup Olivier surtout
Brigitte Ethan qui était face à vous
vous restez avec nous c'est Vincent rond
qu'on va retrouver maintenant en direct
du figuerolive Vincent roubonsoir
bonsoir Elisabeth bonsoir Olivier
Marleix moi j'ai une question de foot à
vous poser est-ce que vous êtes serein
pour le match France - Maroc mercredi je
parle au plan sécurité bien entendu
est-ce que vous faites confiance au
dispositif du gouvernement est-ce que
vous faites confiance au dispositif du
préfet de police de Paris pour faire
face à l'éventuelle débordements
je connais pas encore le dispositif du
gouvernement j'espère qu'en question
d'actualité demain il aura l'occasion de
nous le préciser évidemment que c'est le
genre de match dont on sait qu'il peut
amener des débordements qu'il y en a
déjà eu d'ailleurs sur les
qualifications du Maroc en jus jusque là
donc donc on a des régions d'être
inquiets voilà moi ce que j'aimerais
c'est que les jeunes souvent
franco-marocains souvent la double
nationalité
faites faites le résultat du du Maroc
même ça ou la qualification de la France
ce que je préfère encore avec dans la
joie et comme ils le font comme ça se
fait au Maroc alors au Maroc quand on
célèbre la victoire de l'équipe du Maroc
ça se fait ça se fait dans la joie et la
bonne humeur il n'y a pas de raison
qu'en France ça se traduise par des
incidents
oui qu'est-ce que vous pensez vous vous
dites les que les franco-maréca
devraient fêter la la victoire du Maroc
je sais pas et votre question
d'autres questions Eric Zemmour pense
que les autorités marocaines ne
laissaient pas ne laisseraient pas les
supporters français se répandent dans
les dans les rues des grandes villes
marocaines comme le font les supporters
marocains en France vous pensez comme le
lit c'est un peu ce que j'ai dit
différemment c'est à dire que au Maroc
je pense que je pense que les jeunes
franco-marocains ils étaient en vacances
au Maroc
je ferais ça exprimerait leur joie de
manière respectueuse et purement joyeuse
et donc il y a pas de raison qu'en
France ça se passe différemment voilà
très clairement et donc aux autorités
françaises aussi de faire preuve d'un
tout petit peu d'autorité et de fermeté
si une différence de comportement c'est
aussi parce qu'en France on sait qu'il y
a plus aucun respect de l'autorité par
ne fait plus peur
et donc plutôt l'autoritarisme dans ces
cas-là celui du roi du Maroc
il faut un peu de respect et il faut on
assiste de toute façon à un effondrement
de l'autorité et du respect de cette
autorité ce qui est assez logique merci
Vincent à tout à l'heure pour une autre
question à Olivier Marleix vous êtes en
face distrait le directeur adjoint la
rédaction du Figaro bonsoir et alors une
politique
bonsoir Olivier Marleix alors c'était un
grand jour hier pour votre famille
politique puisque vous êtes donné un
nouveau président qui s'appelle Éric
Ciotti et on se pose des questions quand
même sur cette élection parce que eriki
était donné comme largement favori
finalement il n'a gagné que par 5000
voix d'avance sur son concurrent Bruno
Retailleau est-ce que vous estimez c'est
une belle victoire
oui écoutez c'est une belle victoire
allez allez nette elle est claire et
j'ai une victoire effectivement qui
n'est pas non plus totalement écrasante
donc oblige oblige le gagnant à
respecter le camp des des vaincus et
donc c'est c'est plutôt pas mal
comme il aurait voulu non mais je suis
prête aucune aucune mauvaise intention
non mais en tout cas ça veut dire que il
faut que tout le monde continue à se
respecter voilà
est-ce que c'est une campagne qui était
quand même très très très respectueuse
très courtoise qui sait très bien passé
notamment entre
Eric et Bruno donc voilà nous sommes
très bien est-ce que un des points qui a
peut-être affaiblir la candidature
d'Éric Ciotti c'est justement d'avoir
déclaré très vite que son candidat à
l'élection présidentielle ça serait
Laurent Wauquiez et il l'a répété à
l'envie on sait que c'était pas
tellement le choix non de Bruno taillot
que pour beaucoup de et de cadres du
parti c'était pas la question
essentielle pour beaucoup c'est trop tôt
pour se poser cette question est-ce que
il a fait une erreur là beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs qui souhaitent aussi
l'élection de de la désignation de
Laurent Wauquiez comme candidat avec son
présidentielle ont pu voter pour pour
Bruno retaille parce que Bruno
évidemment c'était toujours Laurent
comme un candidat légitime moi je
partage je partage totalement le
le choix de de d'Éric que nous désignons
rapidement notre candidat avant les
européennes même avant les européennes
je pense que dans la 5ème république une
formation politique elle doit être
incarnée donc
[Musique]
à la fin 2023
la responsabilité du non mais ça vous
semblerait
assez rapidement oui 3 ans à l'avance il
faut désigner avant les européennes il
faut le plus rapidement sera le sera le
mieux désigné notre candidat à
l'élection présidentielle c'est une
nécess dans la cinquième république
d'avoir un candidat
identifié et à fortiori dans l'époque de
hyper médiatisation
moi ce que j'observe c'est que les
candidats de famille politique qui ont
gagné ils ont eu en général le temps de
se préparer Valérie Pécresse désigné 5
mois avant c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible et Jacques Chirac et Nicolas
Sarkozy ont leur temps ils ont eu le
temps de se préparer une tendra sembler
pour que ce soit Laurent Wauquiez sans
passage par des primaires même si hier
alors tout à fait étonnamment érection
nous a parlé d'un processus démocratique
c'est quoi ce processus démocratique
démocratique ce sont les adhérents qui
votent et que ce soit
les odeurs antivotent après vous n'êtes
pas obligé de faire plusieurs mois de
shows
pas
ça aux parties dans dans
en 2000 en 2000 mais 2002 peut-être 7
pour la destination de Nicolas Sarkozy
avec Michel laliomari il y avait il y a
eu un grand congrès des odeurs c'est un
congrès physique c'est-à-dire porte de
la Villette de mémoire et au plus se
présenter ceux qui ont voulu se
présenter et il y a un candidat qui a eu
une inflamation ce jour-là non non il y
a eu un vote ce jour-là est-ce qu'on a
besoin de largement biaisé qu'on a
besoin de Nicolas Sarkozy était biaisée
pas du tout je dis ça désignation par le
parti je crois pas oui mais parce qu'il
faut il est écrasait le match enfin il
était face à des gens qui étaient
inconnus on verra mais n'importe qui
d'autre aura droit de se moi juste comme
ça je vois les choses que c'est pas
obligé de prendre des mois à se ce que
chacun s'oblige ces petits jeux oblige
chacun à cultiver ses différences par
rapport au voisin et pendant qu'on est
là ce genre de match on ne parle pas
français on s'intéresse pas au sujet qui
intéresse les Français simplement on
sent et vous
je voulais te le dire Laurent Wauquiez
quand même la personnalité qui est
probablement la mieux placée est-ce que
vous ne prenez pas en compte le fait
qu'il a été renvoyé à ses chers études
en
18 ou 19 après l'élection 19 après
l'élection européenne ou et bien on a
estimé que certains chez vous ont estimé
que il radicalisaient trop la ligne du
parti Monsieur pécré Madame Pécresse
Monsieur Bertrand sont partis et des
militants sont partis
avant d'ailleurs oui mais ça déplaisait
mais je ne me souviens pas qu'il était
renvoyé à ces études c'est le choix qui
a fait Laurent au lendemain des
européennes d'assumer sa responsabilité
de partir à l'époque je lui avais je lui
avais reproché d'ailleurs de de partir
d'être parti mais oui mais parce que il
a choisi un candidat qui est
François-Xavier Bellamy qui est un homme
de qualité mais qui semble-t-il et bien
n'a pas fait le n'a pas réalisé le score
et la responsabilité c'est tout à son
honneur un échec quand même est-ce que
on peut repartir avec un homme qui a
échoué sur sur son nom dans une élection
à la présidentielle voilà moi je pense
qu'il faut il faudra rapidement de la
clarté un candidat et si
Eric Chiotti nous propose à candidature
de de Laurent Wauquiez la titre
personnel j'en serai j'en serai ravi
alors pour tester la chose est-ce que
vous pourriez pas demander à leur
embauquiez ben de conduire la liste de
votre partie aux élections européennes
franchement je pense que c'est pas le
sujet
au contraire Laurent vocale souhaitait
prendre du champ de la vie dans la vie
politique je pense qu'il est aussi
conscient pas se raconter d'histoires
que aujourd'hui des électeurs de droite
vous en avez un peu partout partout sauf
au Républicain mais j'en avais vous en
avez ailleurs qu'au républicain vous
avez des électeurs de droite chez chez
Emmanuel Macron vous avez des électeurs
de droite chez monsieur Zemmour 100% des
électeurs d'Éric Zemmour sont des gens
de de droite évidemment vous en avez
chez Marine Le Pen et que notre objectif
c'est de de reconstruire
de reconstruire un projet qui s'adresse
à cette frange à droite justement
que à la macronie aux électeurs de
Macron que
vous l'avez justement justement à
changer un petit peu de d'angle de vue
et attendre la main aux électeurs qui
pourraient être contents de Monsieur
Macron élection d'Emmanuel Macron ne
puis-je pas se représenter on est dans
une configuration politique nouvelle où
on sait que les électeurs venant de la
droite Macron seront
invités à rejoindre peut-être Édouard
Philippe nous chercherons à nouveau
chercherons un nouveau candidat pour la
prochaine élection présidentielle
de chacun en politique quel est
l'objectif que doit se fixer selon vous
selon vous en toute sincérité que doit
se fixer érectionti dans les quelques
mois à venir là la priorité elle est où
alors que le pays prend l'État le parti
prend l'eau je pense que c'est vraiment
de raffirmer ce qui est ce qu'elle a
raison d'être profonde des républicains
c'est laquelle alors la raison la
républicain c'est vraiment que de
tourner la page du du macronisme
d'offrir une alternative au mercredi ce
macronisme c'est quoi finalement c'est
ce mouvement politique qui je prétexte
de recomposition aura en réalité éclaté
diviser le pays comme la sans doute
rarement été dans son histoire en
poussant les électeurs de gauche vers
l'extrême gauche en poussant les
électeurs de droite le plus à droite
pour se garder pour lui-même une espèce
de centre et cette espèce de
fracturation du pays on sent elle est
partout c'est les urbains contre les
ruraux c'est les personnes les les
jeunes contre les moins jeunes c'est je
pense qu'on peut pas gouverner un pays
comme ça dans cet esprit de de
fracturation avec un président de la
République qui parfois dit des choses
terribles on va emmerder les non
vacciner enfin donc oui il y a une
stratégie de division des Français moi
je ne peux pas me résoudre à cette
fracturation du pays et le rôle des
républicains c'est qu'on est sans doute
le dernier parti aujourd'hui à avoir
cette ambition de de de de de rostuder
ce pays les gens ne comprennent rien
parce que les gens ne comprennent pas ce
que vous dites si vous disiez on veut
renouer avec l'héritage goliant
faire Pradier et cieux à la fois est-ce
que c'est pas ça qui pense que je pense
que les Français ils comprennent très
bien quand même cette espèce de eh non
parce que ils sont partis chez Macron je
pense qu'ils ont quand même pas fini
c'est la stratégie qui a marché du du
président de la République qui a réussi
à être réélu la peur la guerre tout ça a
sans doute faciliter les choses
aujourd'hui la situation c'est quand
même qu'on a dans un pays qui est
profondément fracturé et je ne pense
avec j'aime bien j'aime bien l'analyse
de du politologue Jérôme Sainte-Marie
qui parle du bloc élitaire contre le
Bloc populaire on peut pas gouverner les
Français comme ça il faudra un moment
rassembler se préoccuper d'unité
nationale toute dernière question le
projet de Marine Le Pen le projet de
Marine Le Pen la dernière question
Laurent Wauquiez devra démissionner de
sa présidence ou ne pas se représenter à
sa présidente si des ces moisies de la
région pardon Rhône-Alpes si ces mois-ci
vous le désignez comme candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
accepteront pas dit mais on veut
la singularité du choix de de Laurence
de ne pas être engluée dans un parti
politique et d'exister en tant que que
comme d'action à la tête de sa région et
je pense que ça n'empêche pas ça
n'empêche pas au contraire c'est sans
doute la meilleure préparation face à un
gouvernement seul d'être un candidat les
pieds dans le
démissionnera pas en tout cas oui
Marleix ne voit pas de raison pour
laquelle il devrait démissionner merci
beaucoup ultra un petit mot quand même
de avant d'accueillir le député
Renaissance qui a la gentillesse de
enfin qui a accepté de débattre et vous
aussi d'ailleurs en vous en remercie
l'incroyable histoire au Parlement
européen des quatre vice-présidents du
Parlement européen a dormi en prison
parce que elle a été prise la main dans
le sac en tout cas avec des sacs de
billets dans son appartement elle est
une des quatre personnes en prison pour
ce catargate elle aurait été elle aurait
cédée à des tentations du Qatar corrompu
il y a 16 perquisitions il y a six mises
en examen quatre personnes en prison
on verra ce que donne l'enquête pour
l'instant ce sont des des présumés
innocents mais faut-il surveiller plus
étroitement les activités des députés et
des députés européens en l'occurrence
pour éviter ce type de scandale de
choses d'abord la première c'est que je
me réjouis je me réjouis de travail de
la justice belge
voilà qui est efficace en France on peut
être ministre de la Justice sera envoyé
devant devant un tribunal correctionnel
sans qu'il se passe rien on peut être
secrétaire général de la présidence de
la République
mis en examen pour une prise illégale
d'intérêts
donc
les enquêteurs
les affaires
judiciaire deuxième sujet sur le
Parlement européen je pense qu'il y a un
vrai sujet quand même sur les ONG je
pense que ça c'est pas un que pour le
Parlement européen il y a un vrai sujet
de transparence sur les ONG aujourd'hui
la transparence sur les hommes
politiques notamment dans notre pays en
France elle est elle est partout
déclaration d'intérêts déclaration de
patrimoine un contrôle de la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique qui est extrêmement extrêmement
pointu en revanche sur sur les ONG les
gouvernementales qui prétendent et qui
incarne dans le débat public une espèce
de morale les gens leur donnent 5 euros
c'est 10 euros même les gens qui ont
très peu de revenus en pensant que que
ce qu'ils font est bien souvent parfois
en tout cas parfois ces ONG sont le
phonet de d'intérêt économiques très
puissants et donc là où je pense il faut
mettre de la transparence c'est sur les
ONG c'est un sujet d'ailleurs que sur
lequel j'espère que la commission
d'enquête sur les causes de la perte
d'indépendance énergétique de la France
doit se pencher parce que notamment dans
le domaine des énergies renouvelables il
y a eu beaucoup de lobbying pas toujours
très sains de mon point de vue vous
dites que là il y a des choses à trouver
merci pour votre réponse et en face de
vous Charles site bien descendu bonsoir
à vous merci
Merci à VOUS Charles vous êtes
porte-parole indépoque parole du groupe
Renaissance encore une fois merci à tous
les deux d'avoir accepté le principe du
débat contradictoire et vous pouvez vous
les commencez justement sur le
positionnement politique du parti LR
dont vous avez en face un digne
représentant le premier des
représentants à l'Assemblée nationale
puisque c'est le président du groupe
bonsoir Olivier marlex je suis retourné
avec vous parce que vous êtes une des
voix importantes de l'hémicycle depuis 6
mois et je voulais commencer par une
petite question est-ce que vous vous
souvenez de ce que vous faisiez le 13
octobre 2016
non non c'est pas une question piège
mais le 13 octobre 2016 c'était le 1er
débat de la primaire de la droite et du
centre d'ailleurs vous y étiez aussi
Elisabeth Martichoux puisque vous vous
l'animiez je vous proposerai pas marqué
effectivement et pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai voulu commencer par la parce que à
cette à cette époque là ce soir-là on
faisait tous les deux la même chose on
assistait on assistait au débat et puis
on était membre de la même de la même
formation politique les républicains qui
qui était la suite de l'UMP puis ensuite
la fin de l'histoire on la connaît tous
on pensait tous que les républicains
allaient revenir triomphalement au
pouvoir c'était quasiment acquis c'était
tout ce qu'on avait en tête et puis
Emmanuel Macron est apparu les
républicains ne sont jamais passées le
premier tour des deux présidentielles
Emmanuel Macron a été élu réélu et
beaucoup de personnes de la droite
coliste du centre droit ont suivi
Emmanuel Macron dès 2017 moi j'en ai
fait j'en ai fait partie et
dans les raisons qui ont poussé beaucoup
de gens à quitter les républicains il y
a eu l'entrée de Tours la présidentielle
de 2017 ou le ou le parti arrivé
lentement mais sûrement à la question et
donc où les républicains n'ont pas été
en capacité de prendre une position
claire pour appeler à voter pour
Emmanuel Macron face à la candidate de
l'extrême droite et je crois que vous
avez fait partie à l'époque de ceux qui
n'avaient pas appelé à voter clairement
pour Emmanuel Macron et du coup je
voulais je voulais savoir je voulais
savoir chaque jour qui passe fait que je
le regrette je ne regrette pas
ma question c'était je n'ai jamais
compris pourquoi ce parti qui avait
toujours été très clair dans son
positionnement face à l'extrême droite
c'est-à-dire aucune les dix très haute
avec commencé à dériver à partir de ce
moment là c'est la question que beaucoup
d'électeurs de droite en fait se posent
depuis six ans pourquoi la dérive telle
que vous la présentez en tout cas oui
enfin pour nous les choses c'est très
simple c'était ni PS ni le RN et on a vu
dans le macronisme l'héritage de du
hollandisme et donc c'était je fais
partie de ceux nombreux ça peut être le
cas de tout le monde mais pour qui
c'était ni Macron ni Le Pen et chaque
jour qui qui passe fait que je ne
regrette pas puisque chaque jour qui
passe montre que
Emmanuel Macron a bien été le jeune
apprenti de de François Hollande on le
voit sur la l'effondrement du pays en
terme de dépenses publiques on le voit
sur l'absence d'intérêt pendant pendant
5 ans à défendre notre industrie dans la
mondialisation on le voit sur des sujets
régaliens on a une immigration qui a
explosé sous Emmanuel Macron on parle de
400 000 étrangers en 2000 en 2021 on
était à on était à moins de 200 000 par
an sous Nicolas Sarkozy donc
effectivement je me reconnais pas du
tout là-dedans et c'est pas le fait que
il y ait eu quelques quelques ambitieux
pour qui être au gouvernement passait
avant leur condition je pense la
question genre c'était pas ça la
question parce que avec Bruno le avec
Bruno Le Maire qui Édouard Philippe qui
qui ont fait des choix par par
ce que vous pouvez formuler la question
plus clairement parce qu'en fait elle
s'est posée en 2017 et également en 2022
quand il y a un choix au second tour
d'une élection présidentielle entre un
candidat d'extrême droite et un candidat
du centre gauche centre droit voilà ça
dépend comment on veut placer manuel
Macron en tout cas du centre un candidat
républicain et qu'on appartient à partie
gouvernement que on ne fasse pas
clairement barrage à l'extrême droite en
appelant à voter pour le candidat de
partie gouvernance qui s'était passé en
2002 lorsque
41,2 % des Français votent pour Marine
Le Pen je pense qu'il est difficile de
dire qu'on est dans
les traités tous de de de fasciste quoi
moi je n'en a pas plus d'alliance avec
avec Marine Le Pen qui avec Emmanuel
Macron
très très clairement notre
positionnement il est singulier je pense
que d'ailleurs les deux les deux se
renvoient la balle finalement
c'est guignol Enya franc quoi enfin
c'est c'est équivalents sont un candidat
du centre et un candidat extrêmement
rapide ils sont complices d'un jeu
politique
Marine Le Pen Emmanuel Macron n'aura pas
été réélu
c'était la candidate idéale l'adversaire
idéal donc je comprends les Français qui
lui ont donné le jeu suffrage d'agiter
d'agiter Marine Le Pen et ça moi si je
je pense que cette voix est totalement
inefficace pour pour notre pays donc la
question elle est très claire vous avez
du rassemblement national de budgeta
qu'on a pas varié on peut nous reprocher
beaucoup de choses
justement moi je dis que depuis Jacques
Chirac beaucoup a changé en fait au
niveau des LR c'est à dire que vous
voyez on a Jacques Chirac et Nicolas
Sarkozy ni d'ailleurs François Fillon
n'aurait eu ses hésitations face à
l'extrême droite
Sarkozy avait autorisé le pratiquer le
Nini aux élections aux élections
régionales donc c'est ni PS ni ni Front
national on est toujours sur cette ligne
là on n'a pas changé et pardon mais
c'est pas vous qui est issu d'un parti
où tout le monde a retourné sa veste qui
allait me donner des leçons de du coup
on parlait du passé moi la question que
j'ai aussi elle concerne l'avenir parce
qu'on a tous suivi ce qui s'est passé en
Italie il y a quelques semaines et où
une première ministre est arrivé au
pouvoir qu'on aborde la question des
soignants au pouvoir parce que justement
la droite l'a aidé à y parvenir et parce
qu'il y a une alliance entre la droite
et l'extrême droite du coup moi comme
beaucoup de Français de droite je suis
assez inquiet ce que vous pouvez me
confirmer qu'il n'y aura jamais
d'alliance entre les républicains et
l'extrême droite j'ai du mal à savoir où
est le fond où est le où est la
République en marche de droite
aujourd'hui moi je fais partie des gens
de droite qui sont allés travailler avec
Emmanuel Macron de gauche et du coup la
question est très importante vous me
confirmer qu'il y aura jamais d'alliance
entre les républicains et l'extrême
droite ça fait ça fait un nombre
d'années donc posez pas de questions de
vous connaissez parfaitement les
réponses voilà on n'est pas
on n'est pas en Italie on n'est pas de
scrutin de ce que tu as parlementaire
sur les élections nous l'élection
maîtresse c'est l'élection
présidentielle et moi je pense il y a
ces Zemmour a fait ce calcul qu'il
fallait faire lumière un peu plus de
finalement de division de division
simple il y aura jamais d'alliance entre
vous ne répondez pas ça fait 30 ans
qu'on fait la même réponse à cette
question donc je veux bien que vous
jouiez des candides ça fait 30 ans qu'on
possède
la République en marche donc il y aura
jamais d'alliance entre les républicains
et l'extrême droite d'accord je on passe
au sujet des questions à vous parce que
ceux qui ont commencé à se retrouver au
jeu dans la partie de qui se proclame de
droite et des députés qui se proclament
on peut demain j'espère qu'on ne
retrouvera pas à l'extrême droite jambe
droite travaille avec Emmanuel Macron le
deuxième sujet il concerne ce qu'on a
vécu le 24 novembre à l'Assemblée
nationale puisque l'extrême gauche la
France insoumise d'apporter un texte de
réintégration des vaccins des soignants
non vacciniens alors moi j'aime pas trop
le terme mais on vacciné je préfère dire
antivax parce que c'est ça la c'est ça
la réalité c'est l'infinité de soignants
qui sont contre contre les vaccins et
qui n'ont pas voulu se ce vacciner et
alors
l'extrême gauche l'extrême droite on
défendu cette réintégration des
soignants antivacs et puis alors moi
j'étais très surpris de voir que les LR
vous avez aussi soutenu la proposition
de la France insoumise et du coup je
voulais comprendre pourquoi vous avez eu
cette position dans l'hémicycle parce
que je trouve qu'il y a une vraie
aberration aujourd'hui à se priver de
personnels soignants
qui ne sont pas malades qui n'ont pas
droit d'aller dans les hôpitaux quand
dans la dans le même temps votre
gouvernement en est réduit dans certains
hôpitaux ou en manque de personnel à
convoquer des personnels peut-être
vaccinés mais malades porteur du covid
vous trouvez ça normal vu qu'on en soit
là donc c'est une aberration absolue je
vous rappelle que vous l'auriez oublié
que nous sommes le dernier pays de
l'Union européenne à ne pas avoir
réintégré les les personnels
d'ailleurs des soignants mais aussi des
des pompiers non vaccinés le dernier
pays de l'Union européenne donc le
président Macron est une espèce de de
savoir scientifique que aucun des chefs
d'État des 27 pays de l'Union européenne
n'aurait tous les autorités sanitaires
sérieuses donc il y a un moment il faut
que le Président vous avez défendu un
texte avec l'extrême gauche et l'extrême
droite pour réintégrer les soignants
anti- il faut que la personne
franchement les mesures de bon sens d'où
qu'elles viennent ils auraient même de
voter des mesures de proposer par la
République en marche c'est c'est dire
donc on vote les mesures qui sont utiles
aux Français c'est notre seul parti pris
dans ce dans cette Assemblée nationale
et quel aberration une fois encore a
demandé à des malades du covid d'aller
travailler à l'hôpital et de laisser des
gens qui a un an ou le malheur de ne pas
se faire vacciner les autorités de santé
là vous minimisez un petit peu
par hasard qui ne se sont pas fait
vacciner c'est qu'ils ont beaucoup
beaucoup j'en connais vous aussi ont des
convictions quand même chevillées au
corps
des
craintes personnelles donc vous pouvez
pas
peut-être oui il y a d'extérieur mais du
coup monsieur Marleix vous parlez avant
des médecins moi j'ai écouté
attentivement un médecin éminent notre
assemblée qui manque de votre groupe qui
est le professeur Philippe Juvin et qui
a dit lors de cette séance que le refus
de se faire vacciner pour des raisons
personnelles et respectable toutefois ce
refus n'est pas sérieux de la part d'un
soignant au contact des malades et je
crois que c'est un argument qui a été
très écouté lors de cette séance et et
je ne comprends pas que vous écoutiez un
député qui vient de votre propre groupe
on a d'autres médecins j'ai beaucoup de
respect d'amitié pour Philippe mais on a
d'autres médecins je pense à Yannick
nodeur qui lui qui lui plaidait à voter
ce texte pour la réintégration Yannick
noder et pas et pas plus responsable que
d'autres il y a peut-être une différence
de point de vue quand on est à la chance
Philippe et chef de service dans un
grand hôpital parisien Pompidou il y a
sans doute moins de difficultés de
recrutement mais quand vous êtes dans un
petit service dans un petit hôpital dans
un EHPAD vous avez une seule infirmière
et bien ça peut poser des questions de
on parle de 1000 personnes une fois
encore
on est le dernier pays européen
expliquez-moi justifie moi pourquoi la
France est le dernier pays européen
parce que je pense que quand on est
soignant quand on est face à des
maladies il y a une étiquette à avoir et
qu'on ne peut pas mais non je crois dans
la religion macronienne on ne peut pas
on ne ce n'est pas Emmanuel Macron qui
dit c'est beaucoup de médecins les
hautes autorités de santé qui le disent
on ne peut pas soigner décemment des
gens on ne croyant pas à ce qu'on fait
c'est bien pour ça que c'est un film
minorité de soignants antivax ont été
ont été suspendus on sait que ce texte
va revenir d'ici à quelques semaines ou
quelques mois puisque la France
insoumise a dit qu'elle allait les
redéposer le texte donc je comprends que
les républicains essayer d'être un peu
dans le bon sens essayer de regarder ce
qui se passe
des soignants qui se sont vaccinés vous
avez été conseillé général je suis
conseiller départemental vous savez
aussi que les directeurs d'établissement
médico-sociaux ne veulent pas venir voir
je connais plein de soignants qui me
demandent le retour des non vaccinants
du genre ça suffit c'est calcul
maintenant on a besoin d'eux etc
vous êtes très propre européen regardez
ce qui se passe dans tous les pays de
l'Union européenne ce qui se passe en
France aujourd'hui est devenu totalement
incompréhensible et indéfendable
à propos de c'est pas vraiment de la
santé c'est à propos de l'IVG vous
n'avez pas pris sauf erreur vous n'avez
pas pris part au vote de la proposition
de loi et les filles sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG nous le
confirmez vous n'avez pas préparé le
nouveau président de LR et pour la
constitutionnalisation l'IVG alors
est-ce que du coup il faut que les
sénateurs à l'air votent la
constitutionnalisation la question il y
a pas de il y a aucun débat de fond sur
ce sujet là et notamment le texte est
posé par la France insoumise sur une
petite contradiction sur collec puisque
là vous avez voté un texte de la France
insoumise de temps en temps la France
insoumise propose des bons textes et
d'ailleurs celui-là était bien meilleur
que le texte de renaissance votre avis
ils ont repris la rédaction
pas du tout votre texte était beaucoup
plus dangereux puisque lui reconnaissait
un ma question il était il ouvrait des
déséquilibres et il faisait disparaître
toutes les périodes
non constitutionnalisée
un débat de fond en réalité sur ce sujet
vous savez depuis depuis la loi veille
depuis la loi veille aucun député
d'aucune formation politique n'a jamais
n'a jamais proposé de revenir sur la loi
veille aucun aucun depuis 1969 donc la
réalité du débat qui ont eu notamment
l'approche des sénateurs c'était de dire
tout ça n'est pas
utile je vous rappelle que Simone Veil
elle-même qui est un petit peu
compétente en la matière et notamment
qui avait un regard sur sa loi disait
que c'était pas nécessaire de constituer
de constitutionnaliser pardon
interdits
qui s'appelle Éric Ciotti dit et pour en
parlera avec avec ses FedEx
auquel vous vous opposez on en parlera
je vous dis le seul sujet c'était celui
de l'utilité de la pertinence de ce
texte après c'est au sénateur de faire
ce qui voudront considérer que ce texte
n'était pas utile moi j'avoue que je
suis parti je suis tout à fait je n'ai
aucune hostilité évidemment
ce qu'on constitutionnalise aujourd'hui
l'IVG je voyais pas ça non plus d'une
grande utilité bon voilà
consensus assez historique en tout cas
ici merci Charles systemstool d'avoir
accepté ce débat Vincent roux on vous
retrouve en direct du Fier de Paris ici
Olivier Marleix Vincent roux et là et à
une question à vous poser
il y a eu de violences attaques
ce week-end d'une usine de cimenterie de
Lafarge à Bouc-Bel-Air dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône alors les activistes ce
sont flattés de mener une action contre
un pollueur vous les comprenez
évidemment que non et je ne supporte pas
cette
activiste
il ne faut encore s'en renvoie la
précédente question m'avait posé c'est
renvoyer à l'effondrement de l'autorité
je pense qu'il y a un problème de de
d'effondrement de l'autorité dans notre
pays on autorise les gens à faire à
faire n'importe quoi vous savez on
pleure en ce moment sur la
désindustrialisations notre pays on peut
on pleure sur l'effondrement le fait
qu'il y ait plus de doliprane pour les
enfants dans nos pharmacies pourquoi
bien simplement parce que on a écouté
pendant des années des activistes
écologistes qui trouvait que les
l'industrie chimique polluait bien le
résultat effectivement c'est qu'on a
tout délocalisé les industriels ont tout
délocalisé en dehors de nos frontières
parfois très loin et qu'on ne produit
plus rien dans ce pays donc à un moment
il faut aussi savoir ce qu'on veut et à
l'état d'arrêter de d'essayer de
s'attacher les bonnes grâces de de ces
gens là et de faire preuve d'un peu
d'autorité à qui je pense quand je dis
que l'État s'attache essaie de plaire
ces bien je pense à ceux qui ont qui ont
qui ont abdiqué devant eux sur sur
l'aéroport sur
une remarque encore Vincent
Gérald Darmanin vous critiquez l'État
mais Gérald Darmanin lui parle
d'éco-terrorisme et compte bien
s'attaquer au sujet ce qu'il a raison
est-ce que vous le soutenez sur ce je
sais pas depuis combien de temps il est
ministre c'est un il devrait postuler
pour l'Académie française parce que
l'essentiel de son activité consacré à
inventer des mots moi je préférerais
qu'il invente moins de mots qui sont un
peu plus efficaces que ministre de
l'intérieur parce que tout ça se produit
sous son magistère si je puis dire la
punchline d'Olivier Marleix merci
beaucoup Vincent roux merci beaucoup
Olivier Marleix avoir été avec nous un
dossier audition publique merci à tous
d'ailleurs merci j'en profite à
l'ensemble de l'équipe qui nous permet
de préparer cette émission Germain
Andrieu elle est nordico en tête et
toute la régie bonne fête à vous merci
vous aussi bonne fête bonne fête de fin
d'année à tous évidemment sur LCP on se
retrouve le 9 janvier bon pied Bonneuil
à 19h30 pour audition publique à très
vite
[Musique]